E
AMERICAN CRISIS.
♪ KAYLEIGH McENANY IS THE
CO-HOST OF OUTNUMBERED AND
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY AND SHE JOINS ME NOW.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME TODAY.
>> GOOD TO JOIN YOU, BEN.
>> Ben: SO, TELL ME A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT YOU THINK OF THE
LEFT'S EFFORTS WHEN IT COMES TO
FINISHING THE ROLE OF MOMS AND
DADS WITHIN SOCIETY AND MAKING
CHILD REARING SOMETHING THAT
MODERN PROFESSIONALS VIEW AS
TOTALLY ABHORRENT AND SOMETHING
THAT WOULD RUIN THEIR LIVES?
>> BEN, WHAT YOU JUST SAID WAS
SO IMPORTANT, SO OFTEN NOT
SPOKEN BUT A MESSAGE THAT
EVERYONE NEEDS TO HEAR.
IT IS A SUBTLE ATTACK BY THE
LEFT.
YOU NAILED IT.
YOU KNOW, IT GOES BACK TO A TIME
WHEN WE ALL USED TO AGREE
PRESIDENT JOHN F. KENNEDY SAID
CHILDREN ARE OUR MESSAGES TO A
TIME THAT WE WILL NOT SEE.
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE A NEW
FATHER.
I'M A NEW MOM.
I WAS RESEARCHING FOR THIS
SEGMENT BEFORE I WENT UP TO WAKE
MY DAUGHTER, BABY BLAKE FROM A
NAP.
AND I WAS READING QUOTES FROM
AOC.
YOU MENTIONED HER IN YOUR
MONOLOGUE IS IT OKAY TO HAVE
CHILDREN IN THIS DAY AND AGE?
SHE SAID THAT ON AN INSTAGRAM
LIVE, VIOXX WENT ON TO
PONTIFICATE WHETHER IT'S ETHICAL
TO HAVE CHILDREN AMID A WARMING
WORLD.
CLIMATE CHANGE NOW USED AS A
REASON TO NOT HAVE CHILDREN.
LOOK, IT'S EVERY WOMAN AND MAN'S
DECISION WHETHER THEY WANT TO
MAKE THAT DECISION TO HAVE A
CHILD.
BUT IF YOU HAVE THAT DESIRE IN
YOUR HEART, A FEW THINGS COME TO
MIND PEE SIDES GLOBAL WARMING
THAT ARE EPIDEMICS.
A PANDEMIC, A CRIME WAVE, BUT
THE LEFT TRYING TO NOW INSERT
ETHICS MORALITY INTO THE
DECISION TO HAVE A CHILD, A
BASIC FAMILY UNIT AND YOU
MENTIONED BLACK LIVES MATTER, OF
COURSE THEY USED TO HAVE ON
THEIR WEBSITE THE FAMILY UNIT
WAS SOMETHING THAT THEY WERE
CHALLENGING.
YOU WERE SPOT ON.
IT'S A SUBTLE MESSAGE BEING
EXPRESSED NOT OFTEN TALKED
ABOUT.
>> Ben: YOU KNOW, KELLEY, THE
KAYLEIGH THETHING THAT IS JARRIS
SUCCESSFUL, RESOURCES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HAVE CHILDREN THAT
THEY CAN'T POSSIBLY THINK ABOUT
BRINGING A CHILD INTO THIS WORLD
AND THEN I THINK ABOUT ALL THE
THINGS WE HAVE GONE THROUGH IN
OUR HISTORY THE CHILDREN CAME
OUT OF THE GREAT DEPRESSION, THE
PEOPLE WHO CHANGED THE WORLD
OVER THE YEARS WHO HAVE COME
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TIMES IN
THE WORLD.
WHAT WOULD YOUR MESS SAGE IN
EACH MOMENT.
MEN AND WOMEN WHO SAY I LOOK
AROUND AT ALL THE HORRIBLE
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING, HOW
CAN I BRING A CHILD INTO THIS?
>> MY MESSAGE WOULD BE EXACTLY
WHAT YOU SAID WHICH IS THAT
FREEDOM IS AT RISK, THAT RONALD
REAGAN SAID IT BEST.
FREEDOM IS ONE GENERATION AWAY
FROM EXTINCTION.
THAT IS WHY WE BRING CHILDREN
INTO THIS WORLD TO CARRY ON THE
MESSAGE TO THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA OF YOUR FAMILY UNIT, OF
YOUR FAITH, WHATEVER THAT MAY
BE, CARRY ON THE VALUES THAT WE
HOLD DEAR.
AND ALSO, THERE IS THE OTHER
COMPONENT TO THIS, BEN.
AND I SAW IT IN THE WHITE HOUSE
AS PRESS SECRETARY, WHERE
CHILDREN NOW ARE BEING PUT LAST.
I HAD DR. SCOTT ATLAS COME INTO
MY OFFICE, TOPPLE ON MY DESK A
STACK OF PAPERS AND SAY HERE'S
THE DATA THAT OUR CHILDREN
SHOULD BE IN SCHOOLS.
ALL OF THE SCIENCE IS THERE THAT
SHOWS THAT THEY ARE NOT
TRANSMITTING COVID AS READILY.
WHY ARE WE AS A COUNTRY PUTTING
OUR CHILDREN LAST.
WHO, WHAT NATION SACRIFICES
THEIR CHILDREN AS WESTERN
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES ARE OPENING
THEIR SCHOOLS AND WE ARE NOT AS
CHILD ABUSE CASES ARE REPORTING
RATHER GOING DOWN CASES AND
HOSPITALS ARE GOING UP.
IT'S REPORTED IN SCHOOLS AND WE
ARE KEEPING OUR SCHOOL DOORS
SHUT.
SO THERE IS THE IDEA OF HAVING
KIDS AND THEN THERE THE IDEA OF
PROTECTING THOSE KIDS ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
>> Ben: WE WILL LOOK BACK, I
BELIEVE, AT THIS PANDEMIC AND
THOSE DECISIONS WHERE THE REST
OF THE WORLD WAS ABLE TO FIND A
WAY TO GET KIDS BACK INTO SCHOOL
AND WE WERE NOT AS BEING AN
INCREDIBLE FAILURE OF
GOVERNANCE.